[Musica]
sono un hacker si sono qui a pescare un
posto dove sono nato quindi sono
contentissime scelte di pescara oggi vi
parlerò di algoritmi e per farli tuffare
nell'argomento dell'argomento vi mostro
questa immagine che qualcuno avrà già
riconosciuto cioè pikachu si parla di un
gioco un gioco che ha fatto molto
scalpore un anno e mezzo fa ed era
pokémon go
questo gioco è stato in grado di
convincere degli adolescenti ad
attraversare rotaie di treni in posti
pericolosissimi ad assemblarsi di fronte
a luoghi pubblici a bloccare anche
entrate sensibili di accesso in varie
strutture addirittura ad amsterdam dove
vivo ma anche a new york il sindaco è
stato costretto a mandare una circolare
per la polizia allertando proprio che
queste situazioni si stavano verificando
in città tutto questo era lì è successo
perché degli algoritmi stavano creando
degli incentivi erano non erano in
contatto effettivamente con quello che
era il luogo dove creavano questi
incentivi creavano questi mostriciattoli
da raccogliere e hanno convinto questi
adolescenti era andare in giro e
presente mettere in pericolo se stessi e
gli altri
questo è il potere gli algoritmi oggi
possono convincerci possono creare
incentivi possono farci credere cose
facciamo un passo indietro adesso nella
storia quando sono stati usati gli
algoritmi per la prima volta in rete
sull'informazione con l'email
l'email è un protocollo che mi sta molto
a cuore in quanto disegnato per essere
decentralizzato disegnato per permettere
alle persone di avere la sovranità sui
propri dati se noi usiamo l'email
possono avere un email su un server
anche aziendale la nostra organizzazione
può avere effettivamente i messaggi su
un proprio server non stiamo usando il
servizio di un'azienda estranea ma
possiamo addirittura averlo anche a casa
anche se nessuno
lo fa però comunque è un è un protocollo
decentralizzato e gli ingegneri negli
anni 60 e 70 che hanno disegnato
pensavano proprio a questo e poi è
successo qualcosa
qualcuno mi sa dire cosa è successo che
non ha reso più decentralizzato questo
protocollo
ve lo rivelo successo lo spam
il male del secolo è successo che
tantissimi messaggi catturano la nostra
attenzione tutto il tempo
e successo che abbiamo avuto bisogno di
filtri per capire effettivamente cosa ci
interessa e cosa no per prioritizzare
perché la nostra attenzione non è
infinita e quindi è successo lo spam è
ad oggi
se vediamo comunque i servizi di mail
che usiamo probabilmente il 90 per cento
delle persone che sono le email questa
non è una statistica esatta ma tiro a
indovinare usano dei server di
pochissime aziende nel mondo sono
veramente poche le aziende che
raggruppano tutte le caselle di mail che
usiamo e badate l'email è ancora lo
strumento più ufficiale che usiamo anche
al lavoro non è un massaggino su
whatsapp è un email
questa funzione di filtro è diventata
quasi umanizzata questi filtri ci dicono
cosa ci interessa sostituiscono quasi
una persona nel farci un servizio nel
giocare con noi in questa immagine
c'è un automa costruito da von kempelen
nel diciottesimo secolo la presentò alla
corte di maria antonietta ed era un
robot vestito da turco che giocava a
scacchi
era un intrattenimento per gli astanti
nessuno capiva veramente come questo
robot giocasse a scacchi il meccanica al
turk il turco meccanico
amazon ha usato lo stesso titolo per un
suo servizio in cui potete sviluppare un
software un'applicazione e avere gente
da tutto il mondo che fa crowdsourcing
usa questo software per svolgere un
compito che voi avete disegnato di fatto
non conoscete non conoscerete mai queste
persone non vedrete mai scompaiono
dentro la macchina ed era proprio questo
è il trucco di von kempelen c'era una
persona dentro che con un sistema di
leve di specchi riuscivo a vedere la
scacchiera sopra ea muovere l'automa von
kempelen era un orologiaio e si è
divertito tanto a fare questa cosa e
secondo me è molto significativa per il
discorso che stiamo facendo è anche per
il bellissimo talk che abbiamo visto da
vancouver
perché abbiamo comunque degli automi
dietro ai quali delle automazioni dietro
alle quali ci sono delle persone perché
facebook sta comunque impiegandole le
persone per fare moderazione del feed
e così anche google il rating l'ha fatto
sin dall'inizio comunque chiedendo alle
persone aiuto e le ha fatte scomparire
dietro l'artificio di un algoritmo e ad
oggi la nostra attenzione è catturata da
qualcosa che non sappiamo esattamente
questo automatismo sostituito dei
giornalisti non sto parlando solo del
nostro schermo non sto parlando solo dei
messaggi che ci scambiamo sto parlando
di un'economia enorme che sta esplodendo
fondamentalmente girano già miliardi
attorno a questa economia economia di
scambio le sharing economist pensate a
tutti questi servizi che usiamo da
airbnb per trovare una casa in giro per
il mondo a huber per trovare qualcuno
che ci dia un passaggio a tender per
trovare qualcuno che di cui ci possiamo
innamorare fondamentalmente gli
algoritmi sono arrivati così in profondo
anche nella nostra intimità ci conoscono
così bene e ci suggeriscono cose che noi
dovremmo seguire
non piacere ma la domanda da porsi è con
chi stiamo condividendo esattamente
tutte queste informazioni
i nostri bisogni i nostri desideri
quello che cerchiamo con chi
e comunque questo qualcosa in grado di
crearci né di nuovi anche c'è un altro
scenario industriale che comunque sta
guadagnando molto terreno nel mercato da
quello dell'internet of things
l'internet delle cose
oggi possiamo immaginare che la nostra
il nostro frigorifero abbia dei sensori
e riesca a capire quello che per noi non
deve mai mancare nel frigorifero e
collegarsi al supermercato e dirgli
prepara questo cestino perché è finito
non sto neanche a sindacare se questo ci
serva o meno perché certe volte avere un
po di interazione anche al supermercato
non guasta ma di fatto tra frigorifero
tostapane lavatrice
abbiamo un sacco di oggetti che si
collegano in rete e sanno cose di noi
del luogo dove viviamo del logo dove
lavoriamo e ancora con chi scambiano
queste informazioni
cosa dicono di noi questi oggetti e
perché alla fine ho finito di deprimervi
da qui il talk cambia e vi proporrò
delle soluzioni che molte persone
intorno al mondo io ho la fortuna di
collaborare ci stanno cercando di
realizzare sono piccole gocce e spero
che vi spirino una e proprio su internet
of things è un software libero e open
source che potete scaricare e installare
come volete e che fondamentalmente vi
permette di sapere cosa succede nel
luogo dove siete
el approccio fondamentalmente è diverso
da quello della sicurezza
avremmo potuto chiamare questo software
watchdog o scivolo firewall tutte queste
questi termini inglesi che fanno un
sacco paura è che usano i militari per
descrivere situazioni orribili invece
abbiamo preso un pendolino abbiamo
realizzato un software che
fondamentalmente gira come un con un
sensore che vi fa vedere visualizza
effettivamente le connessioni che le
vostre i vostri dispositivi anno
se avete un telefonino vi connettete al
wifi
se c'è da usa al posto del router di
casa vedete immediatamente la
connessione doveva con queste grafiche
te oppure potete anche costruire le
vostre abbiamo vari protocolli e ci
potete collegare altre cose
consapevolezza invece di sicurezza
invece che chiedere a qualcuno di
proteggervi
avete uno strumento che quantomeno vi fa
capire cosa succede
trasparenza radicale ma dentro al luogo
dove vi trovate in modo da potersi
confrontare con le persone e anche
comprendere che cosa veramente
navighiamo perché se vedete nello spazio
violetto quelli sono tutti i.com tutti i
domini puntocom mentre quelli colorati
sono quelli punto net.it punto org
quindi già realizzate quanto è comunque
lottizzata l'internet perché è
importante questo tipo di operazione
perché visualizzare l'invisibile che
succede ogni giorno attorno a noi è
molto importante in questo momento
immaginate se qualcuno entra da lì ora e
inizia a urlare va contro quel muro e
inizia a urlare contro il muro cosa
succede qualcuno tutti ci giriamo io
probabilmente mi interrompo qualcuno si
alza e comincia a chiedere a questa
persona come stai cerca di prendersene
cura
ma se il telefonino di qualcuno di noi
qui comincia a connettersi a mandare
spam in rete milioni di email
magari trova anche le email di chi sta
qui comincia a mandarle in giro noi non
ci accordiamo non ci accorgiamo non
possiamo reagire a questo tipo di
situazione
c'è molto più bisogna consapevolezza che
di sicurezza perché possiamo essere in
grado comunque di avere a che fare con
le situazioni anche difficili che ci
troviamo davanti
un altro approccio quello della storia
qui vedete gabriele saverio il direttore
del museo dell'informatica funzionante
di palazzolo acreide in sicilia sopra la
valle di noto che ripara un computer
abbastanza antico un fax di ms digital è
un museo che sosteniamo e che con cui
lavoriamo gioiosamente per mantenere
funzionanti delle macchine del nostro
passato perché conoscere il passato
aiuta a comprendere il presente e anche
a prevedere il futuro
il modo in cui queste macchine venivano
programmati e ci fa capire molto sugli
algoritmi di oggi e questa storia non è
solo boriosa non è solo una storia per
ingegneri è una storia per tutti qui
vedete il team del museo interattivo di
archeologia informatica di cosenza che
ha coinvolto tante persone loro hanno
particolarmente una bellissima
collezione di olivetti ma anche di
giochi e scolaresche visitano e
comprendono e capiscono meglio come
erano fatti computer una volta devo dire
che frequentando queste persone
soprattutto frequentando queste persone
sono diventato un programmatore decente
ho imparato tante cose proprio dal
passato una terza un terzo esempio un po
più complesso non spaventatevi su questa
slide ci sono molte parole è un
approccio proprio agli algoritmi che
cerca di realizzare ed è il software a
cui mi sono dedicato negli ultimi due
anni
tantissimo cerca di realizzare una
virtual machine
a questo punto siamo in beta quindi già
utilizzabile dentro dei piloti una
virtual machine una macchina virtuale
che processa il linguaggio umano come
fosse un codice i riquadri che vedete
quelli colorati contengono del codice in
quel codice lì in questo momento
descrive delle operazioni crittografiche
delle operazioni di autenticazione di
certificazione che alice fa alice
dichiara di essere nel paese delle
meraviglie
chiede un certificato al cappellaio
matto il cappellaio matto di rai
certificatore lo conserva ed è in grado
di farlo di mostrarlo ad altri
personaggi al gatto con gli stivali e
così via
è una certificazione crittografica
questa è una una cosa molto difficile da
contraffare e questo tipo di
trasformazione crittografiche sono alla
base di quello che è effettivamente
tutta la riforma anche nella commissione
europea che sta promuovendo sulla gpr
sul trattamento dei dati eccetera
eccetera
perché usare il linguaggio umano per
programmare queste macchine perché non
siamo solo noi programmatori a poter
sapere quello che veramente va fatto a
poter controllare se le macchine stanno
facendo qualcosa di giusto o sbagliato
c'è un grosso bisogno di
interdisciplinarità di inclusione di
diversità un un avvocato un giurista
capirà molto meglio di me analizzando
questo tipo di contratti cosa veramente
succede ed è necessario mettere in
condizione diverse discipline di
analizzare proprio gli algoritmi perché
sono pervasivi perché ormai sono
dappertutto
l'importanza di questo passaggio è
quella che ci permette di vivere in una
democrazia invece che in una tecnocrazia
nel momento in cui solo noi tecnocrati
noi maghi del computer che poi non
dovrebbe essere magia dovrebbe essere
molto più accessibile a tutti
vediamo posti in una situazione di elite
dirigismo a quel punto come fidarsi più
ce l'ha spiegato molto bene quel talk
come fidarsi di mark zuckerberg di
quella montagna di zucchero filato
dunque la domanda che pongo e che lancio
a tutti gli sviluppatori a tutte le
persone che hanno a che fare con lo
sviluppo anche tecnico in sala che ci
guardano e questa perché stiamo
sviluppando tecnologie veramente e
stiamo sviluppando affinché le macchine
ci capiscano meglio per manipolarci in
alcuni casi oppure lo stiamo sviluppando
affinché noi capiamo meglio cosa fanno
le macchine io credo che quest ultima
domanda
quest'ultima risposta quest'ultima
posizione sia molto necessarie al giorno
d'oggi perché siamo rimasti un po
indietro con lo sviluppo di un umanesimo
che a che fare con la tecnologia che ha
a che fare col progresso ma che rimane
umanesimo una buona notizia
io mi trovo a lavorare con la
commissione europea come scienziato
ricercatore e abbiamo convinto a
elargire fondi per questo tipo di
sviluppi
quest'anno abbiamo lanciato un fondo
ledger project e stiamo finanziando 16
gruppi di persone ventures che vogliono
fare tecnologia che mettono gli umani al
centro della loro importanza del loro
progetto 16 gruppi fino a 200 mila euro
a fondo perduto e l'anno prossimo noi
faremo un'altra di colla quindi se avete
voglia anche voi di mettervi in gioco se
avete un'idea e pensate cavolo ma
qualcosa lo posso fare anche in questa
direzione e vi preoccupa perché ogni
volta che confrontate qualcuno che
chiedete come la mia idea vi dicono noi
ci vuole il business su al profitto
questo non la vendi a nessuno devi
manipolare le persone devi renderli
dipendenti devi fare un'altra industria
che produce acqua e zucchero che ci
rende tutti più grassi no non è
necessario
in europa le cose stanno cambiando e c'è
un'opportunità e vi invito a provarci
un'ultima cosa questo è il mio secondo
te the talk e mi piace usare questa
grande occasione per ricordare le
persone scomparse e questo torcolo ready
con massimiliano chiavaroli che alcuni
conoscono come max o mosè o mandrake un
grande informatico abruzzese ci manchi
max